Transcriptor: Daniela Escobar Valdés
Revisor: Estíbaliz Utrilla López
Vamos al año 2018.
Al sur de Texas, en la frontera entre
Estados Unidos y México,
hay un lugar de reclusión
para niños migrantes
que han sido separados de sus padres
y están a la espera de ser deportados.
Son niños preferentemente
guatemaltecos y hondureños.
Si pudiésemos ver sus caritas,
veríamos reflejadas allí
emociones como el miedo, la incertidumbre
y sobre todo la tristeza de estar
separados de sus padres.
Sin embargo, un día, desde afuera
alguien lanza al interior
una pelota de fútbol
y otra persona atraviesa un tablón
en la reja de este lugar de reclusión
y lo transforma en un balancín.
¿Y qué pasa?
Muy pronto se escuchan risas,
se oyen carreras, están jugando a fútbol.
Están gritando,
ahora sí que son niños.
Estos niños, cuando salgan
de su lugar de reclusión,
van a salir diferentes.
Van a salir más fuertes.
Lo mismo, en menor escala,
pero, no por ello con menos importancia,
ha estado ocurriendo durante
este confinamiento,
esta emergencia sanitaria,
con nuestros niños
encerrados en confinamiento.
A lo mejor en compañía física
de sus padres,
pero no en la compañía afectiva
de padres que, probablemente, han estado
también sometidos a mucha tensión.
Bueno, estos niños
van a volver a las aulas.
Y estas emociones: el miedo,
la incertidumbre,
la pena de no poder estar
disfrutando con sus padres
se van a transformar en conductas.
Y estas conductas van a transformarse
a su vez en problemas conductuales.
Por lo tanto, si los chicos
vuelven a las aulas
y se privilegia lo académico
va a ser un fracaso.
Los niños van a empeorar en sus conductas
y los adultos, los docentes,
se van a desesperar.
Entonces, ¿qué habría que hacer?
Afortunadamente, las autoridades
educacionales lo han entendido
y se ha pensado que lo primero
es la contención emocional.
E incluso se ha empezado a hablar
de una palabra mágica
que no todo el mundo sabe lo que es.
Que es la palabra resiliencia.
Y se ha comenzado a elaborar protocolos
de contención emocional
y se ha empezado a pensar cómo fortalecer
la resiliencia en los niños
cuando regresen a las aulas.
Y todo se ve difícil, complejo
y sin embargo es muy fácil.
Es muy fácil porque ocurre que nosotros,
los seres humanos,
no somos nuevos en este planeta.
Somos muy antiguos.
Tenemos una herencia ancestral,
una herencia de sabiduría
que data de más de dos millones de años.
Y esta herencia ancestral,
es un libro de sabiduría que nos permite
ser resilientes.
¿Dónde está escrito
este libro de sabiduría?
En nuestro genes.
¿Qué es un gen?
Un gen es
una unidad biológica de información.
Por lo general se piensa que contiene
información fija.
Como por ejemplo: el color de los ojos,
si el cabello es rizado o liso,
la estatura, en fin. Pero no.
Los genes contienen
una información muy dinámica.
Y los genes se activan o se silencian
según las circunstancias.
En este sistema ancestral en los genes
está escrita la resiliencia.
Y la resiliencia está escrita
con cinco letras:
La «j» de «juego».
La «r» de «risa».
La «m» de «movimiento».
Especialmente el movimiento libre
en contacto con la naturaleza.
La «i» de «imaginación».
Y la «a» de las «artes».
La expresión plástica, el dibujo.
La expresión teatral, la música, el baile.
Estos genes están en todos nosotros
y pueden estar activos
o pueden estar silentes.
Y estos genes colaboran a
la autocontención emocional
y colaboran también a reparar
los daños emocionales.
¿Cómo poder activar estos genes?
¿De qué manera?
Vamos a verlo enseguida.
Pero primero nos vamos a preguntar:
¿cómo es un niño resiliente?
Un niño resiliente es un niño sereno.
Es un niño optimista.
Es un niño que mira la vida
como si ya tuviese un proyecto,
aunque sea pequeño.
Es un niño que en el aula
colabora con una buena convivencia.
Es generoso. Es muy, muy sensato.
Es reflexivo.
La resiliencia se ha definido
de muchas maneras,
pero podemos definirla como
la capacidad de sobreponerse
a las adversidades.
E incluso salir fortalecido
de estas adversidades.
De manera que no cabe la menor duda,
es muy importante
que podamos tener acciones
que permitan precisamente
que estos genes se activen.
Porque estos genes han estado silenciosos,
han estado mustios en todos
estos largos meses de confinamiento.
En que los niños no han jugado,
no han reído o han reído poco.
Si han jugado, han jugado con videojuegos.
Pero no se han movido,
no han estado al aire libre.
No ha saltado, correr, trepar,
que son las acciones que a los niños
los llenan de energía.
Y tampoco ha habido tanto tiempo
para la expresión artística.
Entonces es necesario
que activemos estos genes.
Estos genes están esperando.
Son nuestro potencial.
¿Será tan cierto esto? Veamos...
Desde hace más o menos dos décadas
en los hospitales donde hay niños
gravemente enfermos
se permitió la entrada de la risa,
del juego, de la imaginación
y de las artes.
¿Y qué se empezó a ver?
Se empezó a ver que los niños tan enfermos
comenzaban a tener una
recuperación más pronta.
Y las altas eran más tempranas.
Pero no solo eso,
estos niños cuando llegaban a sus casas
eran niños transformados.
Eran niños que, de alguna manera,
se mostraban más fuertes,
más dispuestos a tolerar aquellas
dificultades que eran inherentes
a su enfermedad.
Entonces, tenemos evidencias
de que esto es posible.
¿Pero qué es lo que tendríamos
que hacer, por lo tanto?
Es una medida muy sencilla.
Tenemos que abrir los espacios amplios.
No solo en las escuelas, en las aulas
también en el hogar
para que estos genes expresen
la «r» de «risa»,
la «i» de «imaginación»,
la «j» de «juego»,
la «m» del «movimiento» al aire libre
en contacto con la naturaleza
y las «artes», el baile, la música.
La expresión plástica.
La representación teatral.
Los adultos tenemos esa responsabilidad.
Si lo hacemos, vamos a estar colaborando
para que nuestros niños
sean capaces de auto contenerse,
sin esperar tantas medidas
de contención emocional
por parte de los adultos.
Para que los niños sanen esas heridas
que traen muchos de ellos
del confinamiento y de hacinamiento
y probablemente incluso de haber
presenciado violencia intrafamiliar.
Por lo tanto, es una medida muy sencilla,
pero es una medida que nos compromete.
Tenemos que estar dispuestos a abrir
amplios los espacios
y darles a los niños la oportunidad
de activar ese libro
de sabiduría ancestral
que está escrito en sus genes
y poder entonces comenzar desde
el primer día del regreso a las aulas,
comenzar a ser más resilientes.
No perdamos esta oportunidad.